derek chauvin's defense called a former
forensic pathologist
who argued that floyd's history of
hypertension heart disease and drug use
meant it couldn't be argued conclusively
that the cause of his death was being
asphyxiated by the officer
and then he's he's in a situation where
he's been restrained
in a very stressful situation
and that
increased his fight and flight type
reaction and that would during restraint
would be considered a homicide
and you put all of those together it's
very difficult to say which of those
is the most accurate so i would fall
back
to undetermined unlike the prosecution
which has to prove chauvin is guilty of
murder or manslaughter the defense just
has to raise
a reasonable doubt in at least one
juror's mind that chauvin is responsible
for floyd's death
fowler even suggested that carbon
monoxide from the tailpipe of the police
car
adjacent to floyd while he was being
knelt on for almost nine and a half
minutes
may have been a contributory factor to
his death something the prosecution
seized upon
did you see any ear monitoring data
that actually would give you any
information as to
what amount of carbon monoxide if any
would have been in mr floyd's breathing
zone
no because it was not tested it was a
yes or no question
you haven't seen any have you i have not
seen any data
the prosecution suggested fowler had
misled the jury about the science
of asphyxiation and pointed out that
fowler made money out of his medical
testimony
fowler himself is a controversial figure
he's being sued by the family of a 19
year old black man in maryland
who died after being smothered by police
they accuse him of helping cover up
police wrongdoing
as the trial continued in downtown
minneapolis another case of a black man
killed in a police encounter
this time 16 kilometers away in the
suburb of brooklyn center
twenty-year-old dante wright was shot
dead on sunday the officer who pulled
the trigger kim potter
was charged with second-degree
manslaughter those representing the
wright family
ridiculed the idea that potter had
reached for her gun thinking
it was a taser when you look at the fact
that you're dealing with a
26 year veteran
if she didn't know in 26 years the
difference in
size and weight of a gun
as opposed to a taser then how was she a
veteran
in policing how was she
even on the force that long pot has been
released on bail
and once again hundreds of protesters
gathered outside brooklyn centre police
station
to register their outrage at the death
of another
young black man needlessly as a result
of police escalation that just simply
did not need to happen the response from
the security forces
pepper spray flashbangs and the threat
of
arrest in short escalation
shia britancy al jazeera brooklyn centre
minnesota